on commence par l'une des options sur la
table du chef de l'état l'union
nationale comment et avec qui premiers
éléments mathias arese le concept
revient avec force ces dernières heures
un gouvernement d'union nationale et il
la volonté d' emmanuel macron du côté de
la majorité l'ancien premier ministre
edouard philippe plaide en faveur d'une
coalition dont il détermine le périmètre
me paraît qu'avec le groupe des
républicains qui est le plus grand
groupe numérique dans le spectre que je
viens de dessiner il pourrait une
discussion pourrait s'engager et
peut-être avec le groupe socialiste ou
avec le groupe écologiste une discussion
pourrait s'engager ce mercredi les
forces politiques ont continué de se
succéder à l'elysée afin de se prononcer
sur cette éventualité nous sommes
candidats a aucun arrangement a aucune
combine ou à aucune participation à un
gouvernement avec le président de la
république pour la raison que notre
diagnostic politique et je lui ai dit
c'est qu'il ya besoin d'un gouvernement
qui précisément fasse le contraire de sa
politique de celle qu'il a menée et
combattre les effets qu'à la répandue
l'idée est également balayé du revers de
la main par l'écologiste julien bayou
qui se réjouit de l'art
parlementarisation nous écologistes nous
voterons à chaque texte et chaque
amendement en fonction de l'idée que
nous nous faisons de
du bien du pays et bonne nouvelle le
président de la république devrait
clarifier la situation dans son
allocution ce soir à 20 heures avant une
séquence diplomatique de plusieurs
joueurs
et on en débat tout de suite avec emilie
zapolsky bonsoir merci vous êtes
communicante politique denis olivennes
bonsoir je viens du patron de presse
essayiste auteur d'un étrange
renoncement livre publié aux éditions
albin michel chacun également louis aux
haltères bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste à marianne coauteur avec
agathe l'ambré de l'étrange victoire
mâcon l'histoire secrète c'est publié
aux édition de l'observatoire matthieu
croissandeau éditorialiste politique à
mes côtés comme tous les lundis et tous
les mercredis donc bienvenue et merci
d'être là évidemment on va commencer par
la bourse de ce milieu fin d'après-midi
le présent la public s'exprime donc
dolan devant les français dans moins de
deux heures emilie zappa ce qui vous
êtes communiquant de politique me
conseillez quoi telle attitude mais déjà
déjà c'est pas mal de parler parce que
ça fait un long moment qu'on attend un
petit peu une prise de parole mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on n'a pas eu tellement
de campagne de la part du président
candidat pour la présidentielle même
chose pour la législative mis à part un
petit mot sur le tarmac avant de partir
à l'étranger sur le dossier ukrainien le
second tour des législatives quand même
avec un revers pour lui même s'il garde
une majorité relative il ya quand même
un petit peu péril en la demeure des
inquiétudes on sent bien un flottement
et il n'y avait toujours pas de paroles
des manuels macron je pense que c'est
important ne serait-ce que d'accuser
réception en fait du message qui a été
transmis par les urnes des français qui
ne veulent plus un jupiter qui décide de
tout en passant outre le parlement en
passant outre toutes les instances de
décision je pense qu'il ya eu ce message
de la part des français alors évidemment
le résultat c'est que c'est compliqué de
gouverner et d'avoir un parlement aussi
partagez mais c'est le reflet aussi de
la société est quelque part il faut que
le président acquiesce de ça c'est lui
qui est aux manettes on voit bien c'est
lui qui reçoit tous les partis
politiques
elisabeth bande donc on attend de sa
part quelque chose un signe demain et
part à bruxelles il est temps aussi de
dire un petit peu la suite c'est à dire
qu'est ce qui va se passer au parlement
ou conseil des ministres il ya quand
même trois ministres qui doivent
démissionner parce qu'ils ont perdu aux
élections législatives ministre du
logement ehpad ministre des transports
ehpad ministre du numérique donc il ya
quand même quelques dossiers à traiter
des signaux à donner sur la suite accusé
réception effectivement denis olivennes
mais si on parle de l'attitude alors le
mea culpa n'est pas forcément la tasse
de thé de de nos élus emmanuel macron en
tête mais il faut qu'ils aient un peu de
mes amis
franchement je sais pas ma spécialité
châtre m la psychologie du très mauvais
en psychologie en général et des chefs
de l'état en particulier et je pense
qu'il a une équation aux politiques un
réseau surtout
pour beaucoup de commentateurs c'est une
situation où gouvernable difficiles
compliquées ont aussi empoché à voir
dans l'autre sens en se disant que c'est
une transition entre deux mondes comme
toutes les transitions et douloureuse
c'est comme quand vous déménagez que
vous avez dans votre nouvel appartement
il est pas il les cartons son plein et
c'est vous dire zut ai je fait une
énorme bêtise la
cuisine
non c'est affreux on voit bien que les
institutions
et notre culture politique on a une
culture politique est assez hostile
profondément au compromis elle est
plutôt porté l'opposition à la
confrontation on a des institutions
héritées de la monarchie qui se sont
ensuite renouvelé avec le jacobinisme
avec le bonapartisme avec le gaullisme
j'oublie son hôte des ismes mais qui ont
vont tous dans le même sens c'est à dire
un état centralisé une conception
monarchique et absolutisme l'exercice du
pouvoir un despotisme de la majorité
donc on se méfie des collectivités
locales on se méfie de l'opposition on
se méfie de la société civile ça c'est
notre culture et il faut faire basculer
tout ça et le jour bah pas en quelques
jours ça vient de loin probablement ça
vient d'assez loin on a déjà eu des
épisodes au fond
on revient dans ned en train de revenir
probablement plus ou moins à l'esprit
des institutions de 58 plutôt qu'à celle
de 65 postes élection au suffrage
universel du président de la république
on avait un système qui est dont on dit
qu'il est semi présidentiel salle samain
panachage entre la force du président
est le rôle du parlement il avait
basculé dans le semi présidentiel il
était en train de redevenir semi
parlementaire c'est-à-dire que le
président va devoir
dialoguer trouver des compromis avec
annecy pour répondre c'est à une longue
digression pour répondre à votre
question mais je ne t'ai pas des fêtes
vous y arriviez en fait il doit c'est ce
que cela recommandation la plus
naturelle qu'on lui fasse c'est de tenir
compte du réel et de dire voilà je suis
devant une situation nouvelle je peux
gagner je peux la méprise et où je peux
essayer de la maîtriser et la maîtrise
et s'est trouvé une forme de coalition
de compromis d'accord qui permettra de
gouverner avec sans doute louée aux
haltères très on verra bien mais très
peu d'annoncés fin on se demande que
peut-il annoncé dès ce soir même si on
est dans un temps médiatique on veut le
plus raccourci possible on savait déjà
trois jours il n'a toujours pas parlé
mais que peut-il annoncé est ce que la
solution est institutionnel c'est à dire
classique donc changement de premier
ministre et remaniement voire certains
pour les dissolutions jusqu'à
mentalement mais mai soit c'est une
solution institutionnelle classique à
mon avis et vu le personnage et vu ce à
quoi nous habituer il va plutôt essayer
de sortir quelque chose de son chapeau
voilà ce fut le grand débat pour
répondre le gilet jaune par exemple ce
fut se réinventer dans les allocutions
posco vide ce fut la nouvelle méthode
personnes a bien compris ce que c'était
un pendant la campagne présidentielle
mais voilà il a toujours essayé de
mettre un mot nouveau sur une fameuse
méthode qui se veut plus avec vous et
pas lui seul mais il va devoir montrer
quoi qu'il fasse que il a entendu le
message de l'ensemble de la séquence
électorale parce que en fait le message
envoyé par le corps électoral ou en tout
cas ceux qui ont voté mais peut-être
aussi une partie de ceux qui n'ont pas
voté aux élections législatives vient
compléter et compenser le message à
l'élection présidentielle et si je
voulais le résumer je dirais c'est
d'accord pour mâcon parce qu'il avait le
pen en face mais acronis moi je pense
que c'est ça en fait que le corps
électoral a voulu dire le maquereau
nisme verticale avec des réformes à la
schlague telle qu'on l'a connue pendant
un premier quinquennat avec un
fonctionnement de la majorité qui ne
fait pas du tout place au collectif qui
ne fait pas émerger des si dur et puis
surtout avec cette impression qu'ont les
gens de mépris et d'arrogance je pense
que le corps électoral et cette espèce
d'alchimie démocratique curieuse qui
s'est produite dimanche a en fait voulu
faire émerger ce message partagé par des
gens d'obédiences différentes parce
qu'on se retrouve avec à l'assemblée des
députés rassemblés nationale la france
info me lisent la république en marche
et etc mais je pense que lille a eu au
moins un accord de pas mal de français
sur ce message là au président de la
république un petit peu réélu par défaut
et notamment par rush avec marine le pen
mais auquel les gens comme s'ils
voulaient leur attrapé par le col et ne
pas lui laisser les mains libres 52
médailles hommes et on y reviendra pas
forcément aux prises en un public c'est
à dire ça peut être aussi un message aux
oppositions on vous le dit apprenez à
discuter et éventuellement apprenez le
compromis mathieu est ce que vous dites
il était temps pour les autres depuis
dimanche soir on a dû se contenter du
communiqué aussi lunaires que langue de
bois
débité sur un ton de gps se peint
elisabeth bornes et puis c'est tout
alors faut reconnaître à sa décharge on
sait tous depuis de la part de
l'exécutif janvier faut reconnaître à la
décharge des manuels macron que c'était
pas évident de prendre la parole tant
qu' il n'avait pas de solution à
proposer tant la situation politique
semble compliqué on sait qu'il aime
prendre son temps c'est qu'ils détestent
subir la contrainte extérieure il a
toutefois dû s'y résoudre sous la
pression amicale de certains de ses
alliés d'ailleurs qui n'ont pas hésité à
lui dire il faut parler il faut agir
impossible d'attendre la fin de sa
tournée internationale qui doit
l'emmener 2,1 à bruxelles dimanche en
allemagne sommet du g7 puis enfin madrid
pour un sommet de l'otan en début de
semaine prochaine bref il fallait qu'ils
parlent vrai c'est ça c'était un peu la
seule fenêtre pour prendre la parole
alors je que va-t-il dire aux français
ont raison à cette heure ci
et il va évidemment tirer les leçons du
résultat des élections législatives
dimanche il l'a confié à ses proches
réunis à l'elysée selon un propos
rapportés par libération nous entrons
dans le blizzard de fait la situation
est inédite et plusieurs scénarios
s'offrent à lui alors le plus logique le
plus simple plus cohérent c'est en gros
celui qu'a proposé edouard philippe la
formation d'une coalition comme ça se
passe dans de nombreuses démocraties
parlementaires on se met d'accord sur un
programme ça prend du temps on est
obligé de faire des compromis mais au
final on signe et ça peut rouler le
problème c'est que la seule cible
plausible qui était désigné par edouard
philippe dans les propos qu'on a
rapporté salaires et l'herbe ne veut pas
en entendre parler on sait qu'ils n'ont
pas de chef pendant cinq mois c'est
difficile pour eux de s'engager et puis
on a envie de faire ce cadeau a émané
macro l'autre scénario évoqué par le
président la république auprès de ses
interlocuteurs puisqu'on attend même une
confidence de fabien roussel confirmée
par par marine le pen c'est l'idée d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale alors là
on a sur autre chose à une union
nationale c'est seulement sa l'union
sacrée de 14 ou surtout à l'union se
nationale fait le gouvernement de la
république française viendront
provisoire de de gaulle en 45 où il y
avait des socialistes des communistes
des radicaux des mrp bref comme aussi
c'était le lendemain de la guerre comme
s'il fallait tout se retrousser les
manches et comme s'il fallait tout
reconstruire mais là aussi personne
voulu faire ce cadeau le communiste
fabien hossein qui a reconnu d'abord
avoir envisagé peut-être cette question
comme il l'avait fait en 1945 les
communistes
aussitôt rétropédaler parce qu'il s'est
pris une volée de bois vert de la part
de ses alliés est par ailleurs ça pose
comme une grande question est ce qu'on
met le rassemblement national dans ce
gouvernement d'union nationale est-ce
que ce qui était un danger pour la
république est ce que ceux qui ne
s'inscrivaient pas dans le champ
républicain tout d'un coup on voit des
ministres leur tende la main des députés
dire on va chercher les votes et là on
pourrait même les intégrer dans un
gouvernement d'union nationale de toute
façon les intégrer ce serait coûteux
politiquement et ne pas les intégrer ça
sonnait aussi coûteuse politique gagner
donc on revient au scénario initial en
quelque sorte des majorités
deux projets en fonction des textes oui
c'est pas la solution la plus facile
pourtant pas ce que c'est mais c'est
l'option la plus probable faut aller
chercher on l'a rappelé 10 x 43 voix
soit sheller pour certains textes à lire
à droite au centre droit soit chez les
socialistes et les écologistes pour
d'autres textes et puis en cas de refus
ça permet au président de prendre
l'opinion à témoin est en train de faire
la preuve que ceux qui bloquent le pays
c'est pas lui c'est les autres c'est
d'ailleurs pour cette raison qu'il a
reçus tout le monde depuis deux jours
histoire de montrer à l'opinion publique
qu'il voulait en gros et qu'ils étaient
capables d'entendre capable de réfléchir
capable de faire différemment et que le
sait la responsabilité du blocage s'il y
en a un ça sera pas lui
reste enfin l'armé suprême lui faisait
allusion celle de la dissolution elle
est à double tranchant pour tout le
monde en fait car personne n'aurait sur
le papier en fait ni la majorité
relative actuelle parce que dire aux
gens on va voter parce que vous avez mal
voté généralement ça ça finit très très
mal aimé l'opposition non plus ne veut
pas beaucoup sont fatigués n'ont aucune
envie de se relancer dans une campagne
puis surtout beaucoup ont été élus a
très peu de voix aux usa il a manqué dix
mille voix au maquereau nist pour avoir
une majorité absolue à l'assemblée sur
l'échelle du territoire ce qu'ils valent
pas grand chose et donc voilà chacun a
peur de perdre si jamais eu de nouvelles
élections donc on vous soupçonne partie
de poker menteur de poker-menteur pavot
qui s'ouvre et qui risque de durer le
temps devrait durer longtemps
effectivement emily's appel ce qui sûr
sur l'union nationale tient un jus c'est
une vraie question que pose et mathieu
luneau nationale ok mais jusqu'où et
avec qui ça ça peut être une partie de
la réponse il peut en tout cas tendre la
main à sortir vainqueurs et ont il dira
à qui il propose un gouvernement d'union
nationale en tout cas est en tout cas
moi je suis choquée parce que en effet
il ya déjà eu des appels du pied de
certains députés et même des ministres
dupond moretti sur le rn donc on monte
un cran de plus sur cette espèce de
voilà c'est plus c'est même plus le
front républicain la saison travaille
directement avec des personnalités du
rassemblement national moi j'avais été
déjà très choqué quant au soir du
premier tour des élections législatives
y avait pas eu de consigne de vote
à vis du rassemblement national là on
passe à une autre échelle moi j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ces deux éléments
c'est à la fois on pousse à l'extrême le
mode projet vous avez parlé du projet
c'est vraiment ça donc c'est le retour
finalement bien start up nation on passe
par les projets donc on va faire projet
pouvoir d'achat qui veut voter qui veut
se mettre avec moi on va faire écologie
qui veut voter avec mounir a plutôt
cherché à gauche les écologistes assez
poussée à l'extrême cette espèce de
façon de gouverner un petit peu comme ça
on navigue à vue en rassemblant qu'il
veut et c'est poussé à l'extrême aussi
le système du en même temps là c'est
plus dû en même temps c'est du abstract
où c'est à dire qu'il ya plus de corps
il ya plus de corps central de
programmes et d'ailleurs on l'a vu à la
fois la présidentielle est à la fois aux
législatifs c'est-à-dire que je sais pas
mais moi je vous mets au défi de savoir
exactement quel est le programme
d'ensemble sur les législatives ou même
du candidat macron pendant la
présidentielle il y en a plus c'est
simplement un programme qui vise à
attrape tp tout pour faire voter à la
fois pour se faire élire et à la fois
pour avoir les voix pour pour pour faire
voter des lois pourquoi pas c'est en
effet comme disait denis olivennes c'est
une nouvelle façon de gérer on peut
imaginer ça mais il va falloir comment
donner de la cohérence à tout ça et puis
surtout il ya l'urgence moi je trouve
que alors c'est bien on discute on prend
son temps mais il ya quand même des gens
en face de nous il ya des français qui
souffrent du pouvoir d'achat et de
l'inflation qui ont des problèmes quand
même réel
on va pas continuer à faire voter enfin
il ya véritablement une urgence
rationnelle pratique de la vie réelle et
j'ai l'impression qu'on est un petit peu
au dessus donc probablement il va être
dans l'idée que moi j'ai tout fait vous
voyez bien j'ai convoqué tout le monde
comme disait mathieu et je n'y arrive
pas donc on va faire une autre méthode
mais il faut donner anti arrive pas mais
c'est intéressant la question de la
temporalité denis olivennes passe
effectivement il ya un certain nombre
d'urgences le pouvoir d'achat n'est pas
n'est pas la seule et en même temps ce
temps politique qui oblige tout le monde
à attendre voyez ce que je veux dire
pour que ça se décante un petit peu
moins franchement je suis pas choqué
d'abord là encore quand on se compare à
d'autres démocraties dont les résultats
sont aussi bons voire meilleurs que les
nôtres dont la composition d'un
gouvernement la construction d'un
consensus la fabrication d'un compromis
ça prend du temps et donc on est
tellement cette espèce d'urgence
permanente il faut décider impulsivement
dans l'instant ça fait partie de notre
culture politique du clash de la
confrontation est pas du ddt du coup
nous on considère qu'il n'y a pas de
compromis avec des compromissions donc
il pourrait dire j'ouvre un débat qui
n'est go qui peut durer trois mois
quelle horreur ce président jupitérien
et qu'on vend table cette semaine aux
pôles du pouvoir dans les mains d'un
seul fois personnel et de l'autre quand
il prend du temps pour réfléchir et on
dit mais comme que que n'at-il pas pris
tout de suite la décision no ken
contradiction dans les termes je trouve
qu'il vaut mieux prendre un peu de temps
et faire quelque chose de bien que se
dépêcher pour faire des
les bêtises bon ça c'est la maintenance
la deuxième observation c'est qu'il ya
en effet il peut y avoir la majorité au
cas par cas complexes on regarde pouvait
le faire parce que les gants 14 il y
avait un groupe centriste on n'est pas
du tout dans ces situations là donc ça
va être très complexe la grande
coalition avec sympa la grande la petite
coalition avec les républicains c'est
celle qui paraît naturellement sa
position en oubliant même de dire une
chose c'est que 70% des représentants du
parlement sont des représentants du
centre de la droite de l'extrême droite
il ya un message que le ps hussein je le
déplore a à titre personnel mais il ya
un message que le pays a envoyé c'est
qu'on est à droite
du ps a fait un score remarquable par
rapport à ce qu'était la gauche mais ils
n'en représentent que 30% la plantation
nationale donc la coalition avec les
républicains ce serait le mouvement
naturel mais ils paraissent s'y opposer
encore que il faut voir avec le temps
mais il ya un hic chose mais aussi une
négociation qui démarre exactement il ya
une chose intermédiaires qui est un
contrat de législature où ce que les
communistes avaient appelé autrefois le
soutien sans participation c'est à dire
on se met d'accord sur cinq mesures la
retraite le pouvoir d'achat la sécurité
ces questions que sais-je
on nous fait un gouvernement avec lequel
on peut travailler
papa monsieur enfin pas l'actuelle mise
l'éducation nationale et probablement
pas la ministre et puis à partir de là
on vote pour vous mais on ne se mouille
pas au change si on ne prend pas de
responsabilité ministérielle ça c'est
une configuration hybride entre les deux
qu'on imaginait mais tout ça ça prend du
temps c'est un consensus à des quand un
compromis c'est une négociation ça prend
du temps mais il faut qu'on accepte tout
le temps alors pour illustrer ce que
vous venez dire je suis sûr que vous
allez me suivre en régime il ya cette
réaction du nouveau président du groupe
lr à l'assemblée il vient tout juste
d'être
désigné olivier marc l'ex alors c'est
vraiment intéressant et écoutez bien
tout ce qui ne l'emploie comme mot pour
définir une ligne qui dit il pour
l'instant est clair on écoute libre alex
wiens de conduite elle est extrêmement
claire nous sommes un groupe
d'opposition
mais nous allons peut-être qui pourrait
devenir dans cette configuration
totalement inédite un vent d'opposition
qui va être en mesure de négocier des
avancées pour les françaises elles
moselle terre un groupe d'opposition mot
numéro un en mesure de négocier des
avancées pour les français et moi numéro
2 ou d'informations dans un différend il
faut choisir et en plus ça vient d'eux
olivier marleix ce qui n'est pas le
moins anti macro nist de la bande si je
me permettrai il a quand même écrit un
livre qui s'appelle les liquidateurs
pour expliquer à quel point macron était
à la tête d'une élite qui qui qui vend
le pays en fait qu'il est qu'il le pays
il poursuit emmanuel macron de ses
foudres depuis la vente de la branche
énergie alstom general electric avec
cette commission d' enquête qui avait
fait beaucoup parler donc si ce n'est
pas vraiment au barycentre les
républicains dans le comportement à
adopter vis-à-vis des mêmes comment ce
qui est d'ailleurs un signal politique
aussi envoyé aux employés des
républicains qui est nous ne sommes pas
à vendre et nous ne sommes pas ma
chronique d'ailleurs ceux qui sont
d'acronis sont quelque part déjà parti
depuis cinq ans
ensuite sur ce contrat de coller c'est
intéressant ce qu'ils disent à négocier
d'avancé voilà c'est ça on voit déjà
poindre la justification de ce qui
pourrait être le soutien sans
effectivement et tableaux chantés ou
formuler dit
je ne parle t spa quelques mesures ils
ont énormément en commun souvenez vous
il ya deux mois se disent à rip crézé
c'était des plagiaires c'était du
copier/coller 65 pouces et et de la
photo il le surnommaient les
républicains l'avaient surnommé l'homme
photocopieuse même macro mais à quel
moment de sa campagne au début alors
atteint 65 ou à la fin avec la
planification écologique parce que
celle de clients qui suit
sur la base des ratios section sur les
déserts médicaux surveille à vous faire
soigner de penser à la formule qui
définissait les dix postes que ce
qu'odile puisque dit le chef du groupe
parlementaire lorsqu'un diplomate dit
non ça veut dire peut-être lorsqu'il dit
peut-être ça veut dire oui lorsqu'il dit
oui ça n'est plus un diplomate
donc le nom kick et aussitôt corrigé pas
mais on va quand même faire des choses
laisse ouverte la porte probable à une
forme d'accord pour se mettre en avant
c'est sur cinq ou six grands projets
d'affaires structurant mais alors là ça
serait même temps qui serait vraiment
l'a ouvertement
la fusion en même temps mais ça serait
dû en même temps oui ce serait là
puisqu'elle cas déjà et je crois qu'il
ya plus tellement la tentative pour
tomber à gauche fin pour essayer
d'élargir à gauche la majorité des
manuels macron il l'a fait tout le monde
la composition du gouvernement de madame
bornes avec un soin de signaux qui ont
été envoyés et dont le résultat n'a pas
été probant
mais là sa première intuition qui était
de nommer un premier ministre de droite
a été battue en brèche par des gens
notamment castaner ou ferrand qui ont
été battus d'ailleurs et donc la la la
la la petite musique de il faut se
gauchir je crois que là elle a perdu
beaucoup de son brio une fois encore je
regrette mais c'est comme ça et donc là
est assise naturelle qui rompent avec le
en même temps gauche et droite pour se
tourner vers une alliance qui sera
plutôt à droite est-ce que c'est là
qu'elle pays alors il ya aussi
l'hypothèse et se propose à jérémy
huntsman de nous rejoindre tout de suite
de dutilleux de faire voter des textes
sans forcément passer par une majorité
absolue bonsoir jérémy la majorité
sainte dont ils disposent peut-elle être
suffisante la réponse est oui d'ailleurs
au parlement la plupart des textes de
lois sont adoptées à la majorité
relative par exemple pour l'année 2000
21 on a compté sur plus de 900 scrutin
public et bien seulement 12 ont été
remportés par une majorité constituée de
2 189 députés ou plus qui constituent la
majorité absolue alors bien sûr ce sont
des textes importants comme le projet de
loi de finances un texte sur
l'organisation des élections mais c'est
possible car selon le règlement de
l'assemblée nationale la discussion
parlementaire et le vote des textes
peuvent avoir lieu quel que soit le
nombre de députés présents dans
l'hémicycle et avec 245 députés le camp
de la majorité présidentielle pourra
donc faire passer quelques mesures en
comptant sur l'absence ou bien sur
l'abstention de certains parlementaires
et n'aura pas toujours à négocier avec
ses adversaires politiques ça demande
quand même une vigilance accrue pendant
pendant cinq ans oui bien sûr parce que
les 245 députés de la majorité on l'a
compris devront être présents plus que
jamais à l'assemblée s'ils veulent que
leur texte soit voté et surtout ils
devront être présents pour résister au
stratagème des oppositions et notamment
vous le savez ce fameux coup du rideau
qui vise faire entrer par surprise dans
l'hémicycle
un grand nombre de députés au moment du
vote c'est à dire au moment du vote
final et c'était le cas on l'a vu début
janvier lors de l'examen du projet de
loi sur l'instauration du pass vaccinale
est bien les oppositions face à un camp
de la majorité présidentielle qui était
alors en sous-nombre on avait fait
rentrer des députés et obtenu une
suspension des travaux donc il faudra
dire attention et puis a évidemment on
en a déjà parlé sur ce plateau mais il
faut le rappeler le danger de la motion
de censure oui on sait que la france a
soumises a notamment annoncé qu'elle
déposera une motion de censure contre
elisabeth bornes le 5 juillet et bien
cette motion de censure selon l'article
49 de la constitution elle doit être
déposée par au moins cinquante-huit
députés ce qui est possible pour la
france est soumise le vote a lieu dans
les 48 heures suivant le dépôt et son
adoption s'effectue seulement à la
majorité absolue sont à 2 189 députés ou
plus si c'est le cas évidemment le ou la
première ministre doit remettre sa
démission et celle de son gouvernement
au président de la république mais cela
implique en fait que les oppositions
s'entendent sur ce vote autrement dit ce
n'est pas le gouvernement qui doit
prouver qu'une majorité le soutien c'est
l'opposition qui doit réunir elle la
majorité absolue merci jérémy alloués
aux haltères effectivement ce cas de
figure il est il est intéressant alors
je suis je pense qu'au début du du
quinquennat et la lys le tueur il y aura
quand même beaucoup de députés ils
seront présents ils seront ils seront là
pour soutenir ou pas les textes mais
mais mais cette question de la la motion
de censure de trouver une majorité pour
la voter oui pas si évident parce que ça
suppose par exemple de faire voter
ensemble les députés et les fit et ceux
du rassemblement national
plus de l air enfin elle est pas ce n
est pas simple à tous nantais sur n'ont
pas laissé la chance de mener le mâcon
dans son malheur c'est à dire qu'il abat
une opposition unie face à lui il a des
franches qu'il a lui-même renvoyer aux
extrêmes d'ailleurs en les qualifiant
d'extrêmes mais à la limite c'est vrai
il n'y a plus il y aura pour lui ce
spectre la cette épée de damoclès qui
qui va planer c'est à dire les outils
parlementaires qui pourront être
facilement retourner contre un président
fragilisé par le résultat des
législatives alors que c'est une
configuration qu'il n'y avait pas du
tout connu lors de son premier
quinquennat je rappelle que le en 2017
il obtient la majorité absolue avec son
seul parti qui est né un an avant donc
on craque vraiment du tout au tout pour
cet homme devenu président en surgissant
un petit peu de nulle part et qui
aujourd'hui se retrouvent avec ce cette
situation aux contraintes et pour ce qui
est de l'autre camp c'est à dire la
majorité très relative et le l'idée du
pacte de coalition la question même à
supposer que des députés les
républicains veulent jouer le jeu sait
plus quoi faire est ce que vraiment le
message des deux dimanches du scrutin de
dimanche c'est de faire les réformes les
plus à droite qu'à l'envisager les
manuels macron donc celle que seraient
tentés de soutenir les républicains est
ce que sait faire la retraite 65 ans
voire plus s'il ya des exigences plus
fortes sur du côté du groupe l'est
républicain
est ce que c'est vraiment ce message
mais qui était passé l'émoi mon avis
c'est petit bouton un message de
protection c'est à dire
justement quand je disais d'accord pour
mâcon non au maquereau nisme c'était
plutôt un démenti par rapport au
programme les macros pour ceux qui l'ont
lu que effectivement je pense qu'en fait
beaucoup de gens ont voté pour lui mais
sans vraiment s'intéresser au programme
ne serait ce que parce que la guerre en
ukraine l actuel le torrent de
l'actualité ont beaucoup enfouis les
thématiques de l'élection présidentielle
donc et c'est une coalition d'accord on
parle de pacte de majorité de
différentes hypothèses mais pour quoi
faire sur quels fonds et on évitera très
difficile compte tenu du message envoyé
jeu de le faire sur un programme très à
droite et très libérée mais je vois bien
emilie tabaski sur sur l'hypothèse de
cette ce qu'évoquait j'aime bien celle
là c'est à dire faire passer des textes
en avec une majorité
relative et est donc une opinion
publique qui va juger l'attitude des
oppositions
là aussi c'est un enjeu important et
intéressant à analyser c'est est-ce
qu'ils sont dans le blocage absolu est
ce qu'ils sont dans le blocage permanent
est ce que une partie des députés vote
des textes quand quand s'il juge que ces
textes sont conformes à leurs propres
programmes ça ça va être jaugé par le
oui mais c'est le retour aussi de
l'opposition justement au parlement
parce que comme le disait louis
finalement la majorité était absolue ça
se discutait même pas et on parlait même
de députés playmobil parce que même les
têtes qui dépassent et qui était un
petit peu plus à gauche de la majorité
absolue était rapidement rabaisser on
s'en souvient et n'a pas tellement ils
ont essayé de rallier quelques groupes
qui sont fabriqués mais c'était très peu
donc c'est le retour des oppositions et
en effet ça va être intéressant de voir
comment les unes et les autres se
positionne vous le disiez tout à l'heure
sur une motion de censure est ce que la
nuque et le rassemblement national
parfois peuvent se mettre ensemble c'est
pas tellement pour l'instant la petite
musique qu'on entend chacun veut jouer
son rôle chacun veut considérer qu'ils
aient la force d'opposition on a entendu
la petite bataille sur la commission des
finances qui commence déjà qui pourra
avoir le président de la commission des
finances chacun se révèle être la
première force d'opposition
moi je me demande aussi si emmanuel
macron va pas jouer vous le disais tout
à l'heure il s'en est toujours sorti par
une petite
entourloupe mais finalement c'est une
entourloupe parce que le grand débat
convention citoyenne pour le climat on a
entendu parler du conseil national de la
refondation qui a disparu un petit peu
même au moment enfin à peine mais est-ce
qu'il va pas remettre sur la table
l'idée de dire on comprend que les
citoyens ont besoin de prendre la main
sur des réformes aussi importantes que
les retraites que le pouvoir d'achat le
smig des choses comme ça et de laisser
un petit peu la main aux citoyens ça lui
donnerait le temps de s'installer dans
cette nouvelle situation et s'en aller
jusqu'au référendum bien sûr après avoir
parce que c'est aussi ça la logique du
fonds c'est aussi une possibilité pour
court circuiter un petit peu le
parlement mais ça va être intéressant en
effet de savoir moi je me faisais la
réflexion aussi on arrive avec
énormément de député je sais pas il ya
170 députés qui sont très très jeune on
a un renouvellement complet il ya
troisième un nouveau député il ya 300 de
nouveau des coups ça va être intéressant
de voir on sait que ça met un certain
temps et on l'avait vu avec les députés
macro n'ya justement apprendre à prendre
un petit peu à se professionnaliser à
prendre en compte un petit peu parce que
c'est que d'être député d'être toujours
là ne pas s'absenter quand on a besoin
de jeter on va voir cette montée en
puissance on va voir comment ça se passe
côté nubes et côté un rassemblement
national et moi juste une petite
réflexion sur la gauche moi je suis pas
d'accord parce que dans ce vote on a vu
quand même sur la gauche qui a disparu
de la france oui c'est 30% difficile
mais on a vu on a vu des jeunes qui
votait notamment pour la nuque on a vu
qu'il est 42 % de jeunes qui votait pour
la nuque on sait que les jeunes ne
votent pas beaucoup les jeunes c'est
l'avenir c'est les futurs vieux quelque
part et bien c'est le genre de mensonges
avec la rechange avec l'âge là on change
plus exactement à 40 comme à 20 ans
voulait dire qu'il faut les prévenir à
toutes et à tous on ne change pas tout
et pas tous est ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il y a encore cette velléité et
je pense que la nuque a révélé sa sur
des questions comme l'écologie sur des
questions comme le s'occuper des plus
modestes redistribuer je pense que ça
encore des échos dans la france donc
c'est pas encore représentatif de ce qui
se passe
le point je voulais sauver n'est pas
celui-là bien sûr la nu peuvent faire un
gros score et est indiscutable mais
comme dans d'autres démocraties
européennes au royaume uni par et disons
par exemple lorsque le pôle radical et
le pôle dominant de la gauche est elle
écartée définitivement du pouvoir parce
que les électeurs modérés on vient de le
voir ne vote pas poil ce qui serait tout
à fait légitime est possible dans une
autre configuration si le ps et
écologistes ne s'était pas lier les
mains avec l efi on sait pas comment ça
va tourner c'est que il ya une coalition
entre
les forces macro nist et le ps ait eu
élevé et même en allemagne on aurait pu
imaginer une grande coalition avec les
républicains et les maquereaux nist et
la gauche modérée en france est
complètement inimaginable ce qu'on n'est
pas
considéré que vous donnez même pas la
chance au produit c'est à dire que comme
on le disait lannux débarque si la nuque
ça fait un moment que ça existe ça fait
c'est quand même très très récent ces
députés là son nouveau c'est une
génération nouvelle aussi de députés
bien sûr embarqué par l'extrême gauche
on ne sait pas du tout comment ils vont
réagir coalition union nationale cas par
cas vote c'est tout un produit on part
du principe que c'est que c'est des fous
non seulement
le programme économique n'était pas du
tout réaliste faut donner la chance au
produit personne ne dit que ce sont des
fous non non il inclut un fou ça quand
même mieux pas sur ce plateau non parce
qu'ils incarnent une vision la gauche
qui a une vision radicale donc ils font
pour un changement de système en menée
par une gauche radicale qui s'est dit
qu'il faut et c'est une idée qui me
viennent un changement de système lent
changement de paradigme et c'est le
second dossier mais voilà après c'est en
dieu mais est-ce que ce que dit denis
est ce que pense une grande partie des
commentateurs nous sommes partis dès
qu'ils sont des abeilles sociologique et
des anglais plus âgés c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de majorité sociologique pour un
changement de système c'est rarement
comme ça que ça se passe c'est plus
ça veut pas dire par ailleurs juste sur
la façon dont il se comporte on a quand
même un petit peu de rétroviseurs c'est
à dire que sur les jeunes
les 17 et les filles
63 votes aussi plus mobile que le
maquereau nice ça au mieux cette sortie
à jean luc mélenchon et ça vaut ce que
m'a dit jean luc mélenchon là il ya eu
un vote pour désigner le patron du
groupe est une chef bandit date il n'y a
même pas eu de bail sont claires
d'accord entre eux c'est peut-être bien
de
retour
sécher la france est passée
d'ailleurs le fonctionnement interne de
l efi
c'est pour ça mais en tout cas ce que ce
que dit l'expérience des autres pays
européens c'est aussi simple que ça où
la plupart des pays européens la
scandinavie l'allemagne oui mais à la
fin il ya quand même content quand on
voit qu'il ya une classe moyenne
centrale qui est effrayé par un
changement radical de système et quand
la gauche est un leadership
qui est celui de sa partie la plus
radicale je dis pas que des gauchistes
jeu la définit pas et qui est assez ce
qui est favorable à un changement de
système el helou elle s'éloigne du
pouvoir parce qu'elle elle repousse vers
le centre c'était exactement ce qui
s'est passé là les électeurs modérés et
donc celle inverse qui se passait quand
la gauche modérée est aux commandes
c'est ce qui s'est passé en suède un
camp de la gauche réformiste et modérée
est aux commandes là il gagne le pouvoir
quand la gauche est radical règle
générale la n'obtient pas le voir et
quand elle l'obtient c'est bref et voilà
où elle se modère quand elle prendra son
mal de toute façon battle points points
en tout cas elle est allée dans l est au
parlement cette gauche radicale alors
qu'à auparavant elles étaient dans la
rue elles étaient dans les
manifestations et probablement senekal
et ouvre dans la maison
c'est une bouche dans la fonction et
comme on dit tribunicienne c'est pas une
gauche qui veut gouverner c'est tim
gauche qui veut se faire entendre et
d'ailleurs elle joue un rôle d'aiguillon
du changement c'est celle ci paraît pas
inutile et mais elle le gouverneur au
sein de cette nuit à deux députés qui
sont des porte étendards en quelque
sorte et qui prennent très souvent la
parole à laquelle garrido alexis
corbière qui sont mises en cause dans un
article de me confrères du point les
duty plus je lis le chapeau de l'enquète
du point les du député de la france
insoumise et lui en seine-saint-denis
emploi depuis un an et une femme de
ménage sans titre de séjour est soumise
à des cadences infernales papiers signés
aziz zemouri la réponse du couple
garrido corbières tout est faux il est
liste tous les arguments qui ont été
données par le journaliste et le
témoignage de cette femme de ménage
originaire d'alger trentenaire selon le
point tout est faux ils listent toute la
liste des d information révélée par le
point on va pas prendre parti sur le
contenu de cet article évidemment loués
aux haltères mais on peut se projeter
sur la
difficulté pour
ces deux députés je le disais encore une
fois qu'ils sont des figures importantes
de l efi de s'exprimer dans les
prochains jours est-ce que c'est un
caillou qui va qui va quand même
alourdir leurs chaussures ou pas tant
que ça d'après vous monsieur j'ai eu des
problèmes pour leur logement je croyais
histoire il ya quelques années de ça ça
et puis surtout je pense qu'il ya un
autre effet c'est l'accumulation des
accusations de toutes sortes à
l'encontre demande de la classe
politique est en fait je pense que
l'effet cumulatif en fait nous empêche
déjà de distinguer le graphe du pas
grave parce que je pense chaque jour une
nouvelle accusation de sorbs en a plus
en plus de mal à trier et à savoir ce
qui relève d'une part vous exactement et
aussi le vrai du faux donc tout ça est
baigné dans un du coup dans un bain de
relativisme qui
a des conséquences assez mortifère qui
est lui totalement le tous pourris bien
évidemment et puis de ne plus pouvoir
distinguer entre l'élu qui a vraiment
faute et est celui qui est juste victime
d'un règlement de comptes et la
l'occurrence effectivement sur le les
faits allégués je peux pas vous je peux
pas vous en dire plus moi je pense quand
même que les insoumis ils sont si vous
voulez ils ont des figures effectivement
telle que celle là il ya jean luc
mélenchon qui restent le parent quelque
part mais là ils auront quand même aussi
la force du collectif à condition de
savoir réguler ce collectif est la
condition de voir comment se déroule la
suite du dialogue on a vu que c'était
déjà compliqué dès le premier jour avec
les écologistes et les socialistes
d'ailleurs ils signent leurs papiers
leur communiqué dans lequel il nie
toutes les accusations sur papier à en
tête de l'assemblée nationale raquel
garrido et et alexis corbière chi chi %
par ailleurs l'exploitation de la misère
milite pour la régularisation des sans
papiers il ya aussi ça derrière cette
affaire qui ont encore une fois on est à
ses balbutiements on est prudent comme
on l'est toujours sur ce plateau oui
puis malheureusement pour eux ils ont
cessé des causes qui fait peut-être
marche mieux on en a parlé plein de fois
que des accusations de viol par exemple
qui n'ont pas du tout de crédit pour les
français puisque le ministre a bad a été
réélu très majoritairement je crois dans
dans sa circonscription alors qu'il a
été accusé de enfin il qu'il y a eu des
nouvelles accusations de viol oui
évidemment que c'est choquant parce que
ils sont sur la cause sociale et il
embaucherait quelqu'un qui est sans
papiers et l'embaucheraient au lance
pierre mais je pense comme le disait oui
que c'est l'accumulation là on va on va
être un petit peu dans la chasse aux
sorcières côté arènes côté nuxe un peu
côté tout le monde pour vérifier chacun
son cv son parcours peut-être qu'il faut
approfondir ça quand on est député de la
même façon que ministre mais on a
l'impression qu'on y passe tout de suite
c'est une mauvaise image en effet des
politiques et ça ne fait que renforcer
la défiance des français vis-à-vis des
politiques mathieu c'est vrai aussi des
accusations qui le visent
l'un des membres du
et à la francophonie à l'accusé de viol
arrêté gynécologue spécialisé
l'endométriose visiblement il ya deux
plaintes de deux patientes qui
l'accusent de gestes ou le consentement
n'aurait pas été m
changement que je trouve que je ne
condamne pas que je constate c'est
qu'outre fois on une affaire commence et
quand ont été condamnés ensuite quand on
était mise en examen après quand une
procédure et est ouverte maintenant
c'est au niveau du dépôt de la plainte
et il ya même maintenant des affaires
qui débute sans dépôt de plainte
simplement quand elle est une plainte
l'expression dans l'opinion enfin dans
un journal d'une plainte donc on la
présomption d'innocence et d'attaqués de
plus en plus tôt 6 usd 1 vous parliez
des exemples sionneau c'est exactement
ce qu'ils font les pays nordiques donc
si on veut leur ressembler autant la
reprise avait jusqu'au bout ils font
exactement ce système là c'est à dire du
domaine des qui accusations il ya 100
ans à l'écart d'un ministre ou d'une
personnalité de nommage exerce sur
logistique mondiale
par exemple je crois pas le climat je
vous ferai plein dans ce climat nous
géométrie variable et oui il faudra
regarder la série borgen pour prendre
quelques leçons de l'art de la licence
faut me elard d'une coalition allez on
va terminer là dessus remercie beaucoup
évidemment on va suivre le la prise de
parole de des macros à 20 heures et on
se retrouvera sur cette antenne à 22h
avec d'autres invités pour la commenter
la décortiquer voir ce que le président
nous a annoncé je rappelle le titre de
vos livres l'étrange victoire c'est
écrit avec agathe lambres essai publié
aux édition de l'observatoire je pense
qu'on va voir la couverture la voilà et
puis denis olivennes
votre livre un étrange renoncement il
ronge aussi jean titre c'est un hasard
et c'est publié c'est albin michel